the movie opens up with a news channel
stating that it has been 298 days since
the first manned mission to Mars left
from alpha International Space Station
with six astronauts four men and two
women right then the Channel crew
manages to establish a connection with
the captain of the astronauts group
Andre vishnak the reporter questions him
about what their chances of discovering
water on Mars and most importantly
returning home alive in response Andre
replies that he is very optimistic about
their mission as all the crew members
are well trained to do their job next we
see the group of astronauts getting
ready to land their spaceship on Mars
unfortunately at the last second
something goes wrong and their Lander
malfunctions this causes the spaceship
to crash into the Martian surface in the
aftermath the first one to wake up is
Herbert he contacts their instructor
Lowell back on Earth and reports to him
about the crash Lowell wants to know if
everyone is okay but Herbert doesn't
have that information yet he goes to
check on his fellow astronauts asking if
they are all right four of them Luca
Jenny Fidel and Susanna confirmed that
they are okay but Captain Andre remains
silent Herbert gets worried and
approaches the captain's seat only to
find that he's not breathing panicked he
calls Jenny who is the medical expert to
check on the captain she frantically
inspects his pulse and sadly confirms
that Andre died due to a broken neck
from the crash in the following scene
everyone begins checking around the
spaceship to try and make it work again
however they have no idea what caused
the failure and eventually the crash
they even consult with Lowell asking him
to take a look into the database of the
system but nothing shows up afterward
the group gathers in the cockpit and
everyone asks Susanna the second in
command about what they should do next
Susanna just replies that they can do
nothing other than wait for the rescue
team from Earth to arrive there and take
them away hearing this Luca gets enraged
and states that a rescue mission from
Earth will take more than 26 months to
arrive and by that time they will
already be dead moreover they only have
resources for one year in this
precarious situation Herbert is the only
optimistic guy and he mentions a
possible hypothesis for their survival
He suggests using limited resources
right from today so that they can have
more time until the rescue team can find
a way out Herbert also requests his
colleagues work as a team and try their
best to find a solution he then asks
Luca to provide him with a detailed list
of the resources they have after this
Susanna assigns a task to each one of
them Luca is given the task of finding
out the best way to make their resources
last longer similarly Fidel is assigned
to investigate the major reason for
their crash Jenny is asked to make more
space in the spaceship than if the
spaceship doesn't have space what the
hell is it good for while Herbert is
supposed to experiment with the feasible
ways to extract water and oxygen from
the surface of Mars later Fidel shows
Susanna that they've landed far away
from their planned spot he uses
satellite pictures to prove it and
starts investigating why this happened
meanwhile Herbert enters the room and
mentions the way to get oxygen from Mars
without using their main energy He
suggests they use the leftover cryogenic
fuel in their propellers to do this it's
a way way to get oxygen without needing
much energy however Luca isn't too sure
about it he's worried about the safety
of the fuel tanks and using cryogenic
fuel in this way afterward Luca Herbert
and Jenny go outside to bury the dead
body of their Captain once they complete
the task Luca and Herbert make their way
to check into the engines and propellers
meanwhile Fidel speaks with Susanna
praising her leadership capability and
composure in such a tough situation in
response the latter confesses that she
is also afraid of death but cannot
express her emotions as she wants to
motivate everyone moments later the
remaining three returned to the cockpit
with gloomy faces and Lucas states that
they have lost their engines and have no
cryogenic fuel to begin experimenting
with the reactions however Herbert walks
in with a block of clear material
similar to ice and tries to impart
optimism to the others mentioning that
there is the possibility to find water
in the following scene the team
Converses with Lowell and inquires if he
got any information about the crash
Lowell replies with a no and also
reveals that no rescue missions are
being discussed as of late hearing this
Lucas suggests that they hold a meeting
to discuss their chances of survival and
their plans to move forward the scene
then shifts to their meeting where Luca
mentions that they have resources only
to survive for 12 months he also states
that this time frame is not enough for
any Rescue Team to find and take them
back to earth when Susanna asks him how
many of them can survive for 2.5 years
Luca replies that only two of them can
after getting this information Susanna
inquires with everyone if they agree
with Lucas calculation and estimation
when no one objects she takes it as a
yes and begins contemplating their
duties and importance in the ship after
a while Susanna comes up with the
conclusion that Luca being an engineer
knows how to operate and keep the ship
running while Jenny a medic is essential
in every situation at last she says that
the remaining three including herself
need to go on a death Mission and end
their life to let the two survive and
take their messages to Earth Herbert is
a bit skeptical about the idea as he
wants to fight until his last breath but
after Suzanne makes him understand their
main mission he agrees the following day
the group wakes up after their five
hours of peaceful sleep then Susanna
Fidel and Herbert who was refusing to
comply before put on their spacesuits
and get ready to go on their death
Mission these suits are like special
outfits to keep them safe in space to
Lucas dismay Herbert puts some extra
oxygen cylinders in his bag in case of
emergency they hug each other one last
time and say their final words then they
put on their helmets and closed their
suits tightly they finally look like
proper astronauts now next Susanna Fidel
and Herbert step outside the ship it's a
strange feeling knowing that they won't
come back Lucas suggests that they use
bits of energy and Air in their suits to
capture pictures and videos of the
Martian surface they want to share this
with the people of Earth so they turn on
a special device to send the images back
to their crashed spacecraft Susanna and
the two then set off on their five hour
long journey to find the edge of the
valley while walking down a deep gorge
Herbert feels difficulty in breathing
and realizes that his oxygen supplies
are gone with no options he requests his
friends carry on with their Journey
while he sits there and dies peacefully
Fidel and Susanna are devastated to see
their friend go like this but they have
no choice but to continue after a while
Herbert lies down on the Martian soil
and peacefully he pass Ed away but
before he goes he whispers to Susanna
that he wishes he had more time to get
to know her better Susanna says she
might have even dated him if he didn't
have such a dorky name it's a
Bittersweet Moment full of sadness
despite this tragedy Susanna and Fidel
continue their Journey feeling a mix of
sorrow and determination they know
they're doing something important for
everyone back home they walk together
remembering Herbert and knowing that
their sacrifice might help the others
survive as Susanna and Fidel keep moving
forward Fidel starts to feel tired and
suggests that the former should go ahead
while he takes a rest just as he decides
to rest Susanna notices something
strange up ahead a cave-like opening she
walks toward it and realizes that the
walls inside are covered with symbols
and pictures that couldn't have been
made by natural forces it's as though
they were created by intelligent beings
excited and curious she calls for Fidel
to join her and share in this remarkable
Discovery they enter the cave and
explore deeper fascinated by the
mysterious carvings on the walls as they
go further in something unbelievable
happens the air pressure oxygen level
and temperature inside the cave become
normal just like on Earth this is a big
surprise especially when Fidel's oxygen
tanks are about to run out he takes off
his mask and realizes that they can
breathe this air it's a moment of relief
and astonishment however inside the
caves their communication with the
spaceship stops working Luca back on the
ship tries to reach out to Fidel and
Susanna but doesn't get any response
Luca and Jenny begin to worry assuming
the worst that their friends might have
died it's a heart-wrenching realization
to think about but then their own
situation takes a sudden turn for the
worse an alarm blares in the ship's
cockpit indicating that the air inside
the ship is leaking out Jenny starts to
panic and asks Luca what's happening he
explains that the sensors meant to
detect this kind of problem have failed
and reveals the shocking news that about
half of their oxygen has already leaked
away this is a huge problem because even
with just two people left they won't
have enough oxygen to survive until the
rescue ship arrives it means they might
die a year before help comes as the
gravity or lack thereof of the situation
sinks in the leak worsens Luca suggests
that they should make the most of their
remaining time finding comfort in each
other's company in a moment of
desperation he shares a suggestion that
surprises Jenny he proposes that they
should have a physical relationship
because he believes they'll die very
soon how sweet however Jenny declines
his proposition and is determined to fix
the leak and save their lives back in
the mysterious cave Fidel and Susanna
decide to keep exploring the twisting
passages they're curious to see more of
what this hidden place has to offer
while wandering around Fidel
accidentally enters a tunnel where the
pressure is different from the rest of
the cave this Sudden Change messes up
his body making it hard for him to
breathe properly his insides get
squashed and even though Susanna manages
to pull him back into a pressurized area
it's too late Fidel can't breathe and he
sadly passes away this devastates
Susanna but after a bit of mourning she
continues on on her own she goes deeper
into the cave she finds herself in a
spot that's similar to where Fidel lost
his life but this time she notices
another body a creature from another
civilization that used to live on Mars
it's a startling Revelation realizing
that there were beings here before them
meanwhile in the spaceship Jenny puts on
her space suit and goes outside to fix
the air leak but despite her efforts she
can't stop the leak inside Luca gets a
message from Susanna he's relieved to
hear from her and he quickly brings
Jenny back inside Lucas shares the news
with their commander who has managed to
find a way out of the pressurized
tunnels and reconnect with them Susanna
explains that the air in the cave is
safe to breathe and Jenny is determined
to join her there with very little
oxygen left in the ship Luca and Jenny
decide to take a chance they put on
their spacesuits grab their oxygen
bottles and leave the ship behind to
find Susanna they navigate the
challenging Martian landscape and after
a while finally reached the cave to
their amazement they can breathe just
fine inside so uh threesome says Luca
following this the three of them make
some incredible discoveries they've find
a lake with drinkable water which
somehow hasn't Frozen they also come
across simple plants that have managed
to survive and they figure out how to
start fire giving them a way to stay
warm and cook food in the last scene
with their Newfound resources they
decide to try and survive as long as
they can they use the water and plants
to sustain themselves and keep the fire
going the future is uncertain they don't
know if they'll be rescued or if their
survival plan will even work the movie
ends leaving us wondering about their
fate but they're determined to make the
most of their situation and keep
fighting to stay alive on Mars subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching